welcome to this video playing group
master orange from Israel this is master
kufstein right let's just check cost in
and we got a symmetrical English
position where I can go for this quick
Queen c7 line it's been that's been a
while since I studied that be three yeah
okay let's see i'm currently attacking
the seaport and there is an idea to play
a quick d 5 fee i wonder if this is the
case in this exact position or if i need
to castle first yeah i think i need to
Castle first actually
d 5 p.m. that's not really on
this wasn't this was not what I wanted
to do when really okay
yeah this is a typical symmetrical
English position replicas and black has
played Quincy 7 early which is not
helping at all I don't really like it I
Quincy 7 there's some technical stuff
which I fail to remember really with
this plate I need to I need to look this
up later after the game because this is
really not what I wanted to have fits
this is just a position where white is
enjoying a very comfortable game i have
played this type of position numerous
times with white so I I know that it's
not it's not very comfortable okay it's
simply the set upon being a long time
liability but ok at least I have a
relatively good piece distribution for
the structure does endure some pieces
off so that um um I maybe have enough
plane may be here is going to play will
be 21 most likely the only real town to
play that I have is some connected to a
forum okay well the thing is the hope
that black always has is to get some
pieces off especially the Queen's which
means of this position immediately gets
gets to be quite ok because um I can
defend the c7 weakness on
relatively comfortably with Queens off
but here it's not it's not easy at all
okay at least have the a file open night
a six looks looks to work too passive
really if he covers before it's not
clear what the night is doing
brooke a for this would be would be nice
to accomplish yeah i was house I wasn't
so sure what to do about about the
rookie one actually can i go here i
think i should really intending rook a
one and allowing maybe a possible queen
f6 to cover you seven all right i get
some stuff exchange this position can
easily be okay it's bishop on g2 is not
so great ok this is I must do simply
okay if he maybe has got c5 I'm us i
think i should put a stop to that at
least temporarily to f6 problem
okay it's the c5 coming and I don't want
to play look I'm a see Adrienne look a
fall and I will place if I but I don't
see how to how to prevent it and when c5
here I can take before maybe and allow
the sea point to advance this can be
very dangerous okay i play it and play
it conservative limb just going going
for this year
a deep bonus is a bit weak I probably
ruin it kingi a tour time warning
Jeff I just played it very very very
very safe not not risking anything it
just maybe not enough to win
check check check that's probably
probably just the draw check check Brad
Rowland yeah he offered to draw but such
as hell play I mean it's uh it's just
completely dead and I had some chances
here I mean I was worse that's clear it
started off with me being worse but
around here it has clearly shifted in
blacks favor it's not it's it's a matter
of very very precise plant its and
sometimes tricky and blitz to evaluate
stuff like that for example I can take
here but he's got c6 and this this might
be good for black but it also might be
very dangerous with the sea pawns can
can sometimes be supported or yrf 1a6
computer is just unequal completely
equal maybe with some some fourth line
down but it's it's tough to have to play
I mean I just wanted to have this
position where it's clear that black is
better but it's not clear if you can win
yakini aid is probably better but i had
i don't know i was a bit a bit
suspicious about that that the thing is
probably the best that i can accomplish
in general is to win the deep on and
this should involve a trade of night
against bishop and then this is for
against reregistered wrong so the the
only real winning idea
would be to somehow use this look night
combination to attack f2 or something
and this is probably not happening some
check check yeah it's um it's it's a
position where of him the computer is on
minus 0.5 and yeah like is is somewhat
more comfortable but how do you do you
really win it's um it's very tough to
make any progress especially considering
what I just said maybe you win the deep
on you know if it's if it's all working
on I see you win the deep on but not
necessarily the game alright thanks for
watching